so
da bin ich, ups, gerade mal richtig auf das leute, ich entwirre mal kurz mein headset
so, exellent, jetzt passt das alles wieder, also ich mach mal nebenbei ein betriebssystem
update, wundert euch nicht, dass da so viel zeug durchflutscht im hintergrund, ja, doch
gut sein wenn zeug durchflutscht im hintergrund, ne wir wollen das nicht näher ausführen,
oh ist fertig, exellent, also kurze frage vorweg, was hältst du der nun von Venice an
liest, ähm, ich find die möglichkeiten echt geil, was man machen kann, ich war letztens
auf nem server, das hat sich ganz anders gespielt, die haben 3d spotting aus, die haben custom
ladescreen für die map, die haben recht ausgefallene map rotation, die haben den blau filter weg,
eigentlich richtig cool, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es ne huge spieler base gibt, aber
du hast abends eigentlich immer so 4-5 server voll, also ist denk ich ne gute alternative
zu live und spielt sich auf jeden fall besser, also der unterschied, ich hab letztens mal
wieder live gespielt, also der unterschied zwischen 60 tick und live ist halt huge, wobei
ich halt sagen muss, dass das ohne 3d spotting ein bisschen komisch ist auf dem server, weil
ich hab das gefühl ich werd instant weggelasert wenn ich irgendwo mal mein kopf um die ecke
stecke und gegner seh ich nicht, also es ist irgendwie, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
ob das alles so 100% legit ist was da so läuft, ich mach noch mal kurz update, ja ja alles
updaten updaten, alles updaten, bei der gelegenheit starten wir glaub ich auch mal neu, weil
ich hab immer noch silvester hintergrund null, wobei ich könnte das eigentlich updaten,
ich hab da so ein script zum updaten von get wallpaper, anderes script habt ihr nicht
gesehen, das ist einfach nur alles auskommentiert, so alles klar, funktioniert, haben wir extra
wallpaper, exellent, so geupdatet haben wir auch, ok also ich erzähl euch mal was wir
heute machen, ich glaube das ist was, oh wir haben dafür jetzt, wir haben dafür wirklich
ein kommando mittlerweile, ich glaub das ist was wo denk ich auch einsteiger ganz gut folgen
können und ich wollt mir das schon eine weile mal angucken, weil ich hab ja, bevor ich jetzt
lange rum, ich zeig euch einfach mal, ich mein geizhals kennt ja wahrscheinlich jeder
ne, ich mein das ist so die seite wo eigentlich jeder guckt nach seinem zeug, wo sind dann
die ryzen dinger, rützen, rützen, geizhals, ja 5050x, also ich denk geizhals kennt ja
wahrscheinlich jeder und ich spiele schon lange zeit mit dem gedanken, weil geizhals
manchmal nicht so praktisch ist was eigenes zu bauen, was natürlich bei weitem nicht so
viel kann wie geizhals und auch nicht so komplex und umfangreich ist, also ich spiel schon
eine weile mit dem, gibt es ein video kommando für das neueste video, ne ich glaub nicht,
ich glaub nicht das das gibt, wie gesagt ich spiel ja schon eine weile mit dem gedanken
sowas ähnliches mal selbst zu bauen und was ich machen will ist eigentlich ziemlich,
also wie gesagt im vergleich zu geizhals ziemlich primitiv, ich will ne seite machen wo die
produkte drin sind, die grade quasi begehrt sind, die es auch nicht gibt, sei es ne ps5
oder ne amd oder sonst was, das ändert sich immer so ein bisschen, also das was ich halt
auch benutzen würde oder gucken würde und was sich halt schneller aktualisiert, geizhals
ist teilweise echt langsam, geizhals hast du manchmal sachen lieferbar drin stehen die
schon selbst, schon lang wieder weg sind ja und deswegen hab ich mir grad Spaß gemacht
was eigenes, das soll nichts können außer so ein paar produkte tracken, auf den üblichen
hardware seiten, nein nicht in kobol, garantiert nicht in kobol, willst du mal gucken was
so die hauptsächlichen hardware seiten sind und was ich vielleicht noch mache ist ne price
history, ne schöne, nicht so dieses ding was hier in geizhals gibt, warum mach ich ne price
history, so und dann kann man auf die seite gehen und sagen ok ich suche jetzt nen ryzen
5000 eur nix, jetzt kann man einfach nen häkchen auf der seite setzen und sobald es verfügbar
wird auf irgender seite gibt es dann halt ne notification oder es gibt nen ton oder es
gibt die weep variante wo es dann oder was auch immer im hintergrund macht, also youtube
oder was, also einfach nur bisschen webscreate und das in den dashboard, so ungefähr ja
so ungefähr in der richtung, allerdings werde ich dann noch ein bisschen big brain sachen
dabei machen, weil das muss ja auch funktionieren, wieviel muss ich denn hätten damit du dafür
silverlight, silverlight kannst du, ich glaub silverlight kann man gar nicht mehr runterladen
ey nächsten weihnacht machen wir doch schon fortran stream, ne was, quatsch, nein, nein
machen wir nicht, genau wie gesagt, im prinzip einfach nur nen mini geiz, warum hab ich das
jetzt zugemacht, ach quatsch, im prinzip einfach nur nen mini geizhals, komplett feature reduziert
aber dafür schneller, er hat's konfirmed, clip it, da seid ihr schon wieder am start,
es gibt ja sogar auf twitch, ihr kennt das ja wahrscheinlich, vielleicht, weiß ich nicht,
ich glaub so bekannt ist das nicht, es gibt ja auf twitch streams so nach dem motto ryzen
verfügbarkeit und sowas, hier, guckt euch das mal an, die dudes haben hier, die streamen
einfach nur nen price tracker und haben konstant 1133 zuschauer und sowas, allerdings so einfach
tut sich das nicht ja, so und ich werde nutzen, dass ich ein bisschen reichweite hab auf youtube
und twitch und ich werd ne seite bauen, die was taugt, die ich auch benutze und wie gesagt
das schwebt mir schon ne weile vor, weil ich muss sagen so 100% glücklich bin ich halt
mit geizhals wegen der geschwindigkeit nicht, genau und was ich heut mal probieren will,
ich kann euch jetzt noch nicht so viel erzählen was ich einbaue, erstens bin ich mir da selbst
noch gar nicht so sicher und zweitens will ich nicht, dass es jemand anderes macht, nee
mein vorteil ist eben, dass ich das auch ganz gut vermarkten kann, weil ich eben ne gewisse
reichweite hab und natürlich, ja klar affiliate links kommen drauf, aber das wird komplett
kostenlos benutzbar sein und ich werd damit jetzt wahrscheinlich auch nicht so wahnsinnig
viel verdienen, weil es hat nicht jeder shop affiliate links, beispielsweise was was ich,
alternate mine factory die haben glaub ich sowas gar nicht, aber das macht nix, ja die
reiche gibts dann auch mit weep modus, da kann man dann als notification das hier machen,
macht dann wahrscheinlich auch dass du die jetzt einfach auf dem handy in homescreen
adden kannst als pwa, notifications auf ios geht ja nicht, weil apple halt sagt was aktuelle
webgeschichten angeht, also safari ist quasi der neue internet explorer was solche sachen
angeht, also mobile safari ist der neue internet explorer, also ich werd wie wo still, ich
bin mir zwar nicht so hundertprozentig sicher, aber ich glaub ich werd so ne kombination
daraus benutzen, allerdings nicht komplett, weil ich hab mir auch überlegt, ich hab das
übrigens schon alles registriert, ich hab alle domains registriert, ich hab auch schon
twitter accounts registriert und discord ports registriert und alles mögliche, weil ich den
namen eigentlich ganz cool find und ich hab mir überlegt, ich mach noch ne twitter account
dabei und zwar ne twitter account, so zum beispiel sagst du dann hier add max bot, das ding heißt
nicht so, ich bin mir noch nicht sicher wie der service heißt und da kannst du dann sagen
zum beispiel sowas wie 80099 rtx ab 800 euro, das tweetest du dann an den bot und der bot
antwortet dir dann wenn das verfügbar ist, natürlich mit link auf die seite, dass du
im endeffekt vielleicht auch mal ein reflink klickst oder sowas, in der richtung werd ich
wahrscheinlich machen, der pockbot, ich update erstmal, erstmal alles update, warum hab ich
denn webs, moment, ich will webstorm gar nicht update, aninstall, 0w, brauch webstorm gar
nicht und die eap brauch ich auch nicht, aninstall, weg damit, das ist richtig nice
ja die idee, find ich auch und so schwierig ist es nicht, genau und ob ich twitter und
discord bot, ob ich das in dotnet machen werde weiß ich noch nicht genau, ich werd das nämlich
auch ein bisschen asynchron machen, weil ich will nicht, dass der discord bot und der twitter
bot irgendwie in der main application drin hängt oder sowas, ich werd mir dann irgendeinen,
keine ahnung irgendeinen, was weiß ich irgendeinen reddis oder, keine ahnung irgendeinen, was
ist denn grad so angesagte message queue, weiß nicht, irgendwas in der richtung verwenden,
wo ich dann die discord sachen dran hängen, weil ich wills nicht in der main anwendung
mit laufen lassen, nicht dass dann irgendwie, nicht dass ich noch in irgendeiner Art und
Weise irgendeine sicherheitslücke in der main anwendung, was auch immer drin hab und
dann leute über mein discord bot sachen verschicken oder so, hangfire, es gibt, es gibt sachen,
genau kafka ist angesagt, stimmt, das haben wir auch letztens auf der arbeit erst evaluiert
und es ging, das war auch geil, das ist wieder so ne typische stonks story von der arbeit
ne, die haben kafka evaluiert für message queue geschichten, teststation und alles möglich
aufgebaut, hat wunderbar funktioniert, viel besser als dieses in process java zeug, was
wir aktuell haben, ging, aufgebaut, abgenommen, getestet und was kam raus, nie verwendet,
cake wait und dann wirds jetzt wieder abgeschaltet, das ist auch typische, typische business geschichte,
hauptsache geld, ey das war nicht billig, das war nicht billig, ne ne so viel, die haben
das auf vorhandene hardware gemacht, aber das war halt so ne typische stonks geschichte,
so, downloading, was downloadet denn, er hat auch fertig geupdatet, hallo, so chat jetzt
brauch ich mal eure big, big brain, eure, euren huge kopf und zwar, was, du sollst
ich webstorm installieren, alter ich hab webstorm grad deinstalliert, was, ich glaub ich habs
gebackt, weil ich geupdatet hab, weil ich geupdatet hab und dabei hat er das installiert,
genau, also chat, ich brauch mal euer huge brain und zwar, was sind denn, oh Gott, das
war dieser regex, den wir letztens mal von einem im stream haben, ja, aber ich hab immer
noch kobolgedöns auf, kann das mal weggehen und warum installiert ihr jetzt platform.io,
nein ich will auch kein docker, alter wishlist studio, ich will auch das server nicht hacken,
lasst mich in ruhe, also, ähm, ich war markdown preview, ne, ist das nicht eingebaut, moment,
war markdown preview nicht eingebaut, keckw.md in wishlist studio, plupp, was meinste mit
den shopseiten aus, das was der patrick sagt, genau, ja, passt doch, also leute, was sind
so die shopseiten, wo man hauptsächlich in deutschland bestellt, also was ich jetzt,
ne, ne, ne, nicht guides, nur in besser, viel, viel kleiner, viel, viel kleiner als, als
guides halt und auch bei weitem nicht so viel zeug und nicht so viele features und alles,
also leute langsam, langsam, langsam, chat, also ich sag euch jetzt mal was ich hab, amazon
natürlich, das ist das erste, so, und natürlich wie die coolen leute sagen, amazon, warte
mal, wie ging das, so ging das glaub ich in markdown, ne, so, amazon, alternate, lustigerweise
hardwarerad hab ich schon drinne, einfach weil ich ihn kenne und das für den bestimmt
nicht schlecht, dass man da drin steht, äh, minefactory, otto, hat das ibaro vorher gebracht,
oder ich weiß nicht, wer, wer, ich glaub dass ibaro es vorher erzählt, also sprich, äh,
der cute mod bestellt bei otto, wie es aussieht, ähm, den machen wir tatsächlich rein, ebay
darf man auch nicht vergessen, ohne mist, so, und jetzt case king, tohmann, ne tohmann,
äh, wie gesagt, also es, es wird kein guides hals, in form von, ich kann da, äh, jedes
x beliebige produkt suchen, das geht ja gar nicht, da müsst ihr erstmal wissen, was
alles für produkte gibt, ich werd da die sachen rein machen, die halt gerade angesagt
sind, ja, so beispielsweise ryzen cpus, intel cpus, grafikkarten sowas, das was grad, konsolen,
das was, das was grade angesagt ist, reichelt, bestellt man bei reichelt was, ich schreib's
einfach mal aus, notebooks, billiger, ja, wir dürfen auch nicht so, also wie gesagt,
nur die, nur die, wirklich die richtig großen seite, das problem ist, es gibt nicht bei
allem api's, also einiges werden wir web scrapen müssen, deswegen sag ich's auch im, im,
im streamtitel nicht nachmachen, ja, wie man case king scrap, bin ich mir noch nicht sicher,
das müssen wir mal, das müssen wir mal ausprobieren, ich hab aber schon ne idee, deswegen die mögen
das nicht, die mögen das nicht, dass man ihre webseiten scrapt, deswegen, erstens verdienen
sie Geld damit, wenn ich ihnen da leute zu, zu dingse, und zweitens, werd ich mich echt
zurückhalten mit dem updaten, also ich werd keinerlei traffic großartig verursachen, so,
das war ein mediamarkt, bestellt da wirklich jemand online was, cyberport, da hab ich früher
was bestellt, ich mach das mal nach priorität, ich mach das mal nach priorität, also, die
oberen sind auf jeden fall ziemlich beliebt, cyberport bin ich mir jetzt ja zu sicher,
was ham man, was ham man sonst noch, also case king auf jeden fall auch.
Excellent, ich komm drauf zurück, aber die mods sind eh die ersten, die's dann beta
testen dürfen, so, genau, wie gesagt, das da oben sind zuerst mal meine topseiten, und
das da auch auch wo die meisten leute kaufen, geh ich mal von aus, zalando, die zalando
interessiert glaub ich, für technik zahl ich keinen, so, das muss jetzt erst mal reichen,
ich würd sagen, also was ich ausprobieren will heute, wie gesagt, das ist nix großartig
kompliziertes, was ist mit dem q-chat discord, das ist, das ist was vom, achso, du meinst
ich den bot, ja der discord dürft ihr dann auch alle ausprobieren, wenn es soweit ist,
aber ich muss das erst mal zusammenwursten, ja, ice.de, das war ich jetzt nicht auf distortion,
ich hab mich einmal debaten lassen, aber nicht mit der anderen seite, ja, wish aliexpress,
man braucht da nicht alles drin, wie gesagt, wer da komplett alle features braucht, soll
auf guidezals gehen, so gut, wenn ich das eh nicht machen kann, weil die auch ganz andere
datengrundlage haben, und auch viel bessere shop integration und alles, ich soll übrigens
den code neu starten, warum auch immer, ich will einfach was, was schnell ist, nicer notification
options hat, und vielleicht noch ne coole preishistory, das ist alles, das frontend wird
übelst minimalistisch, natürlich gibt es den weep modus, das muss sein, ja, so, und
wie gesagt, ich weiß, die seitenhersteller sind nicht sonderlich scharf drauf, wenn man
ihre webseiten passt, deswegen halte ich mich da auch zurück, aber wie gesagt, letztendlich
kriegen sie geld für, ist auch ok, moin fibs, so, ich würd sagen, mit was fangen wir dann
an, wir probieren mal alternate aus, ob man alternate irgendwie rausgepasst kriegt, irgendjemand
meinte, dass ne seite über cloudflare geht und nicht passbar ist oder so, ne, caseking
glaube ich ist das, geht bestimmt alles, deswegen, wir werden das jetzt gleich ordentlich machen,
das werde ich nicht veröffentlichen, das werde ich aus dem grund nicht veröffentlichen,
weil ich nicht will, dass mir da irgendwie einer nachsagen kann, ich würde zeug veröffentlichen,
wo du quasi, webseiten, also die webseiten sind ja da nicht so scharf drauf, ich will
dann nicht, dass die sagen, ey, hier du hast zeug veröffentlicht, wo leute unsere seiten
mit lahm legen, was ja gar nicht so ist, aber man weiß ja nie, ne, also was ich jetzt mache
ist, irgendjemand hat gefragt, angel, nein, was ich jetzt mache ist, ich geh mal auf alternate,
ich weiß nicht, wie die seite aussieht, was html-mäßig angeht, alternate und jetzt suchen
wir mal, ich mach mal den darkreader aus, weil ich glaub, da machts im endeffekt nur
kaputt, und suchen wir jetzt mal nach keinem 3090 rtx, und ich mach da auch nix großartiges
business-mäßiges drauf, hauptsächlich mach ich das erstmal, weil ich selbst sowas
haben will, dann mach ich da vielleicht ne seite draus, die alle benutzen können, aber
ich hab mir schonmal den namen der seite registriert, weil ich ne richtig geile idee
hab für nen seitennamen, alles kostenlos, ohne dass ich damit großartig was verdien,
außer vielleicht der eine oder andere amazon reflink, so, wenn man sich jetzt mal den source
code der seite von alternate anguckt, sieht man schon, ok, ganzche viel gedöns, und irgendwie
müssen wir jetzt beispielsweise rauskriegen, was davon die grafikkarten sind, bzw wie wir
das abgefragt kriegen, so, und ich seh da zwei möglichkeiten, wie man das ganze auswerten
kann, ist jetzt egal, ob es alternate, minefactory, oder amazon, oder was auch immer, ist im prinzip
egal, also ich seh da zwei möglichkeiten, was man machen kann, der erste, ich mach mal
kurz ne idee auf, deckhex zeug, ja kann durchaus sein, aber ich probiers, alter was ist mit
der schriftlos, das sieht ja aus wie 1920, als hättest du mal nen obber gemalt, ich versuchs
mal eher mit nem parser, als das mit raygex, wir machen mal ne neue solution, x the solution
ist am start, ach ne komm, komm leute wir nehmen, gibts eigentlich schon, gibts eigentlich schon
dotnet 5 hier, komm wir machen ein dotnet 5 projekt, wir machen ein dotnet 5 projekt,
das ist besser, exquisite, wo haben sie denn das versteckt, hier haben sie irgendwo versteckt
wo man umstellen musste, dotnet, wo ist das da, warlibsnapdbin, große kacke, das find
ich doch nie im leben, hä, guck mal da hat es gefunden, wo hat er das eben, eben stand
es auch noch nicht drin, bin ich jetzt total verwirrt, wat, das stand doch eben nicht drinne
oder, kommt das jetzt auf einmal her, hat er das jetzt aus dem clipboard rausgeholt oder
was, null, na gut, also machen wir ein neues projekt, das darf ruhig mal console app 2
heißen, das ist ok, ich will einfach mal ein bisschen ausprobieren wie man so ein krams
von der, von der website herunter kriegt, raider ai, ja, ich könnt mir echt vorstellen
dass es aus der zwischenablage hat, siehs glaub ich ein tick laut oder, monster hunter
stells, so, excellent, äh, schriftgröße ist gut ne, hatten wir schon öfters, hier
haben wir ausprobiert, schriftgröße ist gut, kann man alles lesen ne, chat, huge, massive
big brain chat, ne, ich benutzt nicht das agility pack, ich benutze das da zum html
passen, ich find das viel nicer, angle sharp, excellent, aber mal gucken, ich hab nämlich
eine andere Idee, also wir haben jetzt zwei, zwei möglichkeiten, wir nehmen jetzt einfach
eine alternate zum testen und wie gesagt, das ist nix was man eigentlich machen sollt
weil die seiten mögen das nicht, wenn man da massig traffic bei ihnen verursacht nur
weil man irgendwelche sachen rauspasst, wir waren jetzt mal exemplarisch am thema alternate,
ich mein verboten ist es auch nicht, ja, aber die mögen das nicht, ähm, genau, so, und
wenn ich jetzt quasi hier nen curl drauf mache, da krieg ich total viel, da krieg ich
halt den source code von der seite, der source code von der seite bringt mir jetzt nicht
allzu viel und ich hab auch die vermutung, dass das nicht wirklich funktionieren wird,
weil, wie gesagt, so seiten wie caseking oder bestimmt auch alternate leiten das entweder
über irgendwelche proxys um oder haben irgendwelche erkennungen drin, wenn du da mit den üblichen
tools dran gehst, keine ahnung, ich glaub das einfachste ist, wirklich, man tut so als
wär man nen browser, der debugger von rider den mag ich auch nicht, mir gefällt der visual
studio debugger viel besser, deswegen fangen wir jetzt einfach mal an und machen nicht
die ganz primitive variante, da gibt es bestimmt schon fertige frameworks für, nö, wie soll
es denn fertiges framework geben für das parsen von deutschen shop seiten, ich weiß
wäre cool, wenn es das gibt, aber das gibt es mit Sicherheit nicht, so, und wir nehmen
einfach dann andere, ach für scrapen, ja bestimmt, bestimmt, aber wie gesagt, ich glaube das
rauskriegen ist gar nicht das problem, das eigentliche seiten abrufen ist das problem,
so, und was wir jetzt nehmen werden, weil damit hab ich schonmal was gemacht, das ist das
wo mich mein domain registrar gebannt hat, das hab ich euch ja schonmal erzählt, wir
nehmen das da, wir nehmen puppeteer sharp, das ist unter der haube nen chrome, den man
fernsteuern kann, ohne, dass man nen fenster dafür braucht, also unter der haube ist das
nen chrome, den man aber nicht sieht, der einfach im hintergrund läuft, den man fernsteuern
kann, das heißt wir tun so, als sind wir einfach den chrome, und somit kann ich auf alle seiten
zugreifen wie ich will, solang da keiner anfängt captchas zu machen, dann hab ich gelitten,
ja, wurdest du nicht zweimal, ne also, ich hab mir ja mal bei diesem, check out magenta.gay,
unavailable, hat sich einer von euch registriert, chat, ich habs mir nicht registriert, moment,
ich habs da noch, ich habs da noch im wahren korb drinnen, ach ne, ich kann das mir nicht
registrieren, weil die telekom irgendwie trademark, what the fuck, ok, egal, ich will gar nicht
magenta.gay registrieren, ich mach mal kurz hier die seite aus, zumindest, hier hab ich
meine domains registriert, einfach nur weil die billig als fuck sind, ich mein, guckt
es euch mal an, ok,.gay ist teuer mit 27,.org domains kosten teilweise 3,50 im jahr
oder sowas, so, und bei denen hatte ich die domains, der domain registrat den empfehle
ich aber nicht, der ist nicht so wahnsinnig, so wahnsinnig gut, was flashbang, na da mach
ich wieder dunkel, der domain registrat ist einfach nur billig, der ist nicht so wahnsinnig
gut, ne, die liegt nix, und wenn die was liegt, bin ich da eh mit fake account angemeldet,
weil ich keinen bock hab, dass mein echter Name da drin steht, zumindest hab ich dort
ein paar domains registriert, und damit man sich zertifikate für die domains ausstellen
kann, macht man das entweder über den öffentlichen webserver oder über dns, ich machs über
dns, das ist am einfachsten, und das blöde an diesem domain registrat ist, die erlauben
es nicht automatisiert über irgendeine api, den dns einträge zu machen, und das braucht
man damit man zertifikate automatisch im hintergrund erneuern kann, so viel kurzvariante
davon, ja, und da hab ich mir gedacht, weißt du was, scheiß drauf, du nimmst einfach einen
ferngesteuerten chrome und klickst das webinterface von denen an und machst darüber dns einträge,
hat auch funktioniert, hat auch funktioniert, leider hab ich das ein bisschen oft ausgeführt
und die haben mich gebannt, dann hab ich den support angeschrieben, grimks your mom, zwei
monate, moin, und dann haben die mich gebannt, dann hab ich den support angeschrieben und
hab gesagt, hey, ich hab versucht, ich war ehrlich, ich hab gesagt, ich hab versucht
eure webseite zu passen, das mit dem dns zu machen, habt ihr eine dns api, dann müsst
ich das nicht machen, dann haben die geantwortet, ja, wir mögen das, aber nicht, und dann hab
ich gesagt, ja, ok, dann lass ichs bleiben, dann lass ichs bleiben, und dann haben die
mich wieder freigeschaltet, und dann hab ichs voll verkackt, dann hab ich das gleiche script,
was ich genommen habe, für das automatisch klicken bei meinem domainanbieter, hab ich
umgeschrieben für was anderes und hab vergessen alle einständige domain auszuführen, und
dann hab ich 20 mal hintereinander gestartet, da war ich wieder gebannt, ja, und dann hab
ich die nochmal angeschrieben und hab gesagt, Leute, ich hab mich vertippt, ich hab's halt
ehrlich gesagt, ja, ich hab gesagt, ich hab mich vertippt, ich hab das angepasst, ich
wollt euch da gar nicht mehr drinnen haben, das war es jetzt wirklich, und die hauen keine
Anzeige raus, das ist ja nicht verboten in dem Sinn, und naja, zumindest haben sie mich
da wieder freigeschaltet, und daraufhin hab ich mir gedacht, ok, wenn mein domain registrar
so doof ist und hat keine dns api, geh ich einfach zu cloudflare, und seitdem läuft
mein dns über cloudflare und alles ist gut, ok, also legen wir mal los, wie gesagt, das
ist ein chrome zum fernsteuern, das ist ziemlich easy, was heißt dns, naja, wenn du eine domain
hier eingibst, dann musst du die erstmal auflösen zu einer api, wo dann letztendlich
der webserver drauf legt, und das ist das, was dns macht, namen zu apis auflösen, so
der bekannteste dns dürfte so 8888 von google sein oder 8884, 4, oder 1111 von cloudflare,
1111, ja ne, cloudflare, oder, glaubst du, war cloudflare, der chat rebadet mich, ich
sehs, aber das ist normal, das bin ich gewöhnt, was, 1001, echt, ist das auch cloudflare,
also ich hab, ich hab bisher nur 2 dns verwendet, die letzten, keine ahnung, 8 Jahre oder so,
also 8888, ne, 8888, und 11111, reich, offiziellen telekom oder unity media dns verwendet, also
ich würd sagen, wir gucken uns mal ein paar samples an, wir nehmen jetzt mal exemplarisch
alternate, und wie gesagt, die mögen das nicht, und deswegen sag ich auch, sollte man
nicht machen, ja, magenta.g, kaufen wir uns auch nicht, packw, so, jetzt installieren wir
den kram erstmal, zack, protip, ping 1.1.1001, exquisite, installieren wir den kram und gucken
uns mal ein paar beispiele an, warum hab ich eben, warum, warum seid jetzt eigentlich auf
einmal alle am start, warum lassen die eigentlich, ist so viele leute am start, grad instant
für die uhrzeit, warum lassen die eigentlich solche endungen zu punkt gay, ist doch eigentlich
schon zu viel, es gibt alles mögliche, also du kannst mittlerweile so ziemlich jegliche
top level domain, die es gibt, registrieren, ist also ne frage des geldes, ja, gibt es
punkt kappa, muss ich mal kurz gucken, crayface, no space, punkt kappa, ne, also punkt kappa
gibt es nicht, das war das erste, kann sich ja noch irgendjemand dran erinnern, das war
die erste, eine der ersten twitch copypastas, die überhaupt existiert haben, kappa gleich
crayface, no space, so lang seid ihr wahrscheinlich alle gar nicht auf twitch, über und sechs
monate, dankeschön exquisite, massive iq sub, kengin sagt, hatte mal ein background service
geschrieben, der ein paar instant startet und in der weilschleife immer bei einer bank
irgendwelche daten anfangen, ich hab allerdings vergessen, dass nach einmal anfangen immer
x sekunden gewartet, ja das solltest du machen, naja gut gededost hast du die nicht wirklich,
also es sei denn die sind mit 56k modem online, aber die mögen das halt nicht, wir machen
das jetzt mal exemplarisch mit, wir nehmen mal alternate, danach probieren wirs mal mit
amazon oder minefactory oder sowas oder case king, wen haben wir da noch, einfach nur mal
gucken, wir nehmen mal zum testen, wir nehmen mal zum testen alternate, so, also, beispiel,
kinderproma, so, was das macht ist folgendes, ich mach mal einen, public class, cute chat,
irgendwas, egal wie das jetzt heißt, void, irgendwas, vollkommen wurscht, search, input,
also, was bringt ihr das am ende, dass ich sehe, sobald neue cpus vorhanden sind und
neue grafikkarten und ich direkt was einkaufen kann, kann ich jetzt mal entscheiden mit ihrer
syntax hier, willst du dir echt ne 3090 holen, ja, will ich, will ich echt, so, also wie gesagt
was das hier macht ist, das ist ne chrome, allerdings den sieht man nicht, aber den kann
man fernsteuern, ähm, zeig euch das mal, so und, ups, wir suchen jetzt mal nach keiner
3090 rtx oder sowas, so und was das ding jetzt macht ist, das lädt sich den chrome im hintergrund
runter, was hab ich jetzt verkehrt gemacht, achso, ja, ähm, also was das jetzt macht
ist, das startet im hintergrund nen chrome und geht auf die seite, die man angibt, also
gehen wir mal jetzt auf, nehmen wir das da, das was in dem beispiel drin steht, nur dass
man mal sieht, dass es funktioniert und dann gehen wir mal das html von der seite aus,
stopp content, get content, genau, so, also was das jetzt machen sollte ist, das lädt
sich im hintergrund nen chrome runter, startet den chrome, ruft über den chrome die seite
ab, gebt das html aus und beendet wieder alles, ähm, ne, wo muss ich hin, rider, übrigens
wenn ihr irgendwas wissen wollt, schreibt adwupplos dabei, weil sonst seh ich das nicht,
äh, es ist in letzter zeit tatsächlich immer relativ viel los, warum jetzt auf einmal 365
Leute, das vielleicht weil ich ein bisschen so ein bisschen äh, äh, spannenderen titel
heute hab, keine ahnung, normalerweise krebsen wir so um die 250, 300 rum, warum jetzt auf
einmal 365 Leute da sind, weiß ich nicht, aber wahrscheinlich wollen sie alle ihr hirn
vergrößern, was ja bekanntlicherweise durch jeden prime sub von alleine passiert, so also,
run, run, so, der sollte jetzt den chrome runterladen, auf developer.google.com gehen
und den quelltext ausgeben, das kann übrigens ein bisschen dauern, ah guck mal da ist er,
nice, übrigens guck mal jetzt geht das auch viel schneller, weil der muss den chrome nur
einmal runterladen, warum geht das jetzt kaputt, kann es sein, dass ich das nicht richtig beendet
hab und der noch im hintergrund jetzt rumkrebst oder so, das war keine gute idee, also, wer
hat dann hier gesabbt alles, muss ich mal kurz gucken, pomsen, 22, danke schon für
den sub, iq++, file 1 für sieben, dankeschön, huge subscriptions und dann haben wir top flanzi,
docks fame, fünf monate schon, huge, massive chat, hab ich das irgendwie verkackt oder
so, kann das sein, warum geht das jetzt nicht, sonic paul, dankeschön für den sub, overlay,
zwei monate am start, aber sowas von, mit python und requester hast du das in paar codezahlen,
tja, aber da hast du nur requester, da hast du kein chrome im hintergrund laufen, der browser
dinger machen kann, das scam train ist erfolgreich leute, das scam train macht grad mein komplettes
chatfenster voll, ich seh überhaupt nix, stufe zwei abgeschlossen, ja nice, ich würd dir
gern das chatfenster sehen, jetzt nicht, machs mit elektron, ja genau, ich hoffe ich hab
nix zu übersehen, damn charx, stufe eins, dankeschön für den sub, so ok, was hab ich
jetzt verkehrt gemacht, warum kacken das jetzt ab, warum will das jetzt nicht, hab ich jetzt
den chrome im hintergrund laufen den ich vergessen hab zuzumachen, muss ich den irgendwie exit
am ende machen oder so, naja anscheinend nicht, warum hängt der jetzt, ok wir machen aber
ein bisschen debug, wir machen big brain console debug, so wie sich das gehört, breakpoints
sind für kack noobs, könnt ihr auch im vorstellungsgespräch sagen, einfach wenn ihr euch fragt wozu
verwendet ihr breakpoints, so sagt ihr breakpoints verwendet man nicht, go to website, wir gehen
mal auf ne andere website, google.de, eben ging es da noch, ah ich glaube die haben irgendein
rate limit drauf auf developer, developer.google, ja ok alles klar, also dann probieren wir
das mal aus alternate.de, gucken ob wir da den quellcode von kriegen, ja funktioniert,
exquisite, dann können wir den tollen debug wieder raus machen, ok das heißt so kriegen
wir schon mal den quellcode von alternate und der große vorteil davon ist gegenüber
dem was der chat eben vorgeschlagen hat, der chat hat eben vorgeschlagen dass man sowas
hier macht, client gleich htp client und dann sagt client get alternate, das ist das gegenstück
zu dem was einer gesagt hat python und request, das geht in, das geht in sie schreiben auch
in paar zeilen aber der nachteil davon ist sobald man ein bisschen advancedere sachen
braucht, sobald man vielleicht irgendwelche cookies handeln muss oder sobald man irgendwelche
javascript dinger im hintergrund laufen hat, dass die seite überhaupt richtig aufgebaut
wird oder sowas in der richtung geht das nicht, deswegen machen wir das so und so kann man
eigentlich alles abfragen, weil es ist halt ein chrome, es ist ein ferngesteuerter chrome,
was der macht ist, der geht her, startet ein chrome, halt headless also ohne fenster, soll
ich den mal mit fenster starten, dass ihr seht das es funktioniert, ich starte den chrome
mal mit fenster, da werdet ihr sehen da startet wirklich ein chrome im hintergrund, geht auf
alternate und macht die seite wieder zu, nachdem er es abgerufen hat, so und wenn ich da headless
gleich tru und dann gibt es kein browser fenster, letztendlich brauchen wir das browser fenster
nicht, es geht ja nur darum, dass man den quelltext kriegt, so und sollte diese seite
jetzt irgendwelche sachen erst mit javascript rendern und machen und tun, dann krieg ich
das so mit, weil das halt ein richtig echter browser ist, exellent, so machen wir das,
der stelzor teilt die belohnung, massive brain, und der stelzor hat einen stufe 1 geschenkt,
nämlich wer hat es gekriegt, tizjan oder tiz, tizjan, wahrscheinlich spricht man das
nicht so aus, eigentlich macht headless keinen sinn, sollte bodyless sein, ja, aber es heißt
halt oftmals headless, wenn du auf dem software irgendwelche dinger startest, ohne gui und
so, da sagt man halt erstmal headless, ja, aber headless ergibt eigentlich wirklich
wenig sinn, weil den kopf hat er ja noch, funktionieren tut er, tobi kot, twitch prime,
dankeschön für den sub, alter leute jetzt können wir, guck mal hier, level 3, hab ich
euch eigentlich schon erzählt, wenn der hype train auf level 5 ist, twitch mason, 9 monate,
dankeschön für den sub, wenn der hype train auf level 5 ist, dass es verbuckt ist, wenn
man nämlich hype train level 5 auf 100 prozent kriegt, dann hört es nicht auf, das geht
immer weiter, quasi twitch kaputt, ja, das ist gar kein chibate, das stimmt wirklich,
ja klar ist das intended, weil die wollen euch weiter scammen, die wollen euch weiter
chibaten zum sub, ok also, wir können jetzt schonmal den alternate sourcecode abrufen,
der website ist schonmal gut, da können wir jetzt da drinne gucken, ob da steht, ach
was gucken wir denn da mal, auf lager oder so, strong class stock status available, können
wir gucken, ist doch schonmal was, moment ich muss mal mein dashboard aufmachen, dass
ich die ganzen subs nicht übersehe, das ist mir gerade im chat ein bisschen zu viel auf
einmal, es ist ja mittlerweile der stream manager, twitch hat das ja umbenannt, madra
mlg, mlg legit, 1 min vor 1 min hat es gesagt mit prime, huge prime subscription, dann haben
wir noch den baladi für einen monat, nice, heute hat es aber echt was los, killphil hat
auch noch sub, alter leute heute wird es aber übertrieben, der kopf platzt gleich, der
ist schon immer so, der kopf der ist schon so bei allen, ok also wir kriegen den sourcecode
von alternate und da können wir jetzt gucken, ob der so Sachen findet, wie z.b. bei der
grafiker, wir machen mal was anderes, wir suchen nicht nach einer 3090 rtx, wir suchen
mal nach einem ryzen 50, da gibt es nicht so viel, das ist glaube ich ein bisschen einfacher
als erstmal 50, 5090, 5090 oder 5950, 5950x, so genau, da gibt es nämlich nicht so viel
und da haben wir auch schon eins, der ist liefertermin unbekannt und der ist auf lager, ok,
das ist nice, das ist nice, ok, da können wir jetzt mal gucken, ob wir das finden in
der webseite, also, wir müssen gucken, ok jetzt müssen wir das irgendwie ein bisschen
raus passen, das ist natürlich komplizierter, jetzt haben wir hier das ding, warum ist jetzt
von der musik eigentlich nur noch rauschen übrig gerade, wir haben 3090 auf lager, ja
anscheinend, äh nicht 3090 3000, ja anscheinend, so, also, das heißt wir brauchen erstmal
irgendeine klasse für dieses item, also sagen wir sowas hier, wie zum beispiel keine product
info oder sowas, public class product info, so und was interessiert uns davon, das interessiert
uns ob das ding vorhanden ist, nennen wir das mal is available, ich hoffe ich hab das
richtig geschrieben, ähm, dann, falls wir das ding mehrfach abfragen müssen, machen
wir hier mal das datum rein, wann ich das zuletzt abgefragt hab, also sagen wir sowas
wie, oder updated add oder irgendwie sowas, da bist du ganz sicher was man damit anfangen,
so, dann brauchen wir noch den name, das ist in dem fall dann sowas wie, die amd ryzen
9 5050x processor boxed oder was auch immer, dann, nach was man da sucht, suchen muss,
so ein 5050x processor boxed, boxed, ja, dann findet er das ding genau, da sieht man aber
schon das die alle so ein bisschen fuzzy search drinne haben, weil man auch andere sachen
findet, ja gratis versand, ne, gratis versand bei 1000 euro cpu, excellent, ups, falsch
die mode, noch die id oben in der uhr, jaja das mach ich jetzt auch gleich, aber ich muss
den kram ja aus der, aus der seite rausfischen irgendwie, also, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken
wie die seite aufgebaut ist, also wir brauchen den ersten hit, also sprich, also search result
box, und dann den ersten list row, genau, baut er sich den eigenen webshop basierender
auf alternate, nein macht er nicht, ich versuche alternate den, den produktstatus abzufragen,
cool, so, also jetzt haben wir den, ok, das ganze html zeug kriegen wir schon mal raus,
das heißt jetzt müssen wir gucken, wie macht man mit puppet hier abfragen, page, gibt es
was wie select, query selector, genau, sowas brauche ich, query selector, also, das heißt
wir suchen jetzt das erste element mit class list row, ich glaube das dürfte doch sogar
recht einfach sein, also ähnlich wie guides also, nee, nee, nee, viel simpler und schneller
dafür, also was brauchen wir das, irgendjemand hat doch gerade im chat was gesagt, man kann
was, rechtsklick, copy selector oder sowas machen, ach nee, nice, geht das jetzt, kann
ich das einfach, kann ich das einfach so, nee eben nicht, wobei das ja nicht stimmt,
ich will ehrlich gesagt, ich will einfach nur das erste haben mit class, mit class list
row, gucken ob das funktioniert, list row, funktioniert das jetzt, anscheinend nicht,
sonst wird der jetzt nicht hängen, ok, wie, wie, wie, und wie sagt man da, time out, kann
man hinten noch ein time out angeben oder so, auto by script für pc teile, ja sowas
wäre auch nicht schlecht, ach ich hab die falsche url, ich kack noob, stimmt, wir haben
das richtige noch gar nicht gemacht, alter, seht ihr mal, ich hab die falsche url, lul,
das heißt bevor wir das machen, müssen wir überhaupt jetzt mal was ganz anderes machen,
wir müssen erst mal die richtige url aufrufen, also machen wir die ganze krempel noch mal
weg, so, also, dann machen wir das jetzt mal richtig, diesen ding ding chrome browser
wollen wir natürlich nur einmalig starten, nämlich einmal pro instanz von dieser klasse,
so, kann man sich das jetzt merken, wie macht man das jetzt am besten, äh, kann man, kann
man, kann man erst so einen constructor machen, ne das geht nicht, oder, dann machen wir irgendein
damit, aber das geht bestimmt, irgendwie sowas, so, options, headless true, will es ja nur
einmalig starten, heißen deine metoden auf der arbeit eigentlich auch immer so, ja, die
heißen bei mir keqw zum beispiel, alle ohne scheiß, ich hab wirklich schon dinge eingecheckt
die keqw hießen, warum machst du das in c-sharp, weil das ja, weil das später eine.net core
web anwendung wird und ich natürlich den kram, der das parsen von der webseite macht, nicht
in der anderen sprache machen will, ne jetzt ohne wüsste, ich hab schon übelst den plötzchen
teilweise eingecheckt, auch oftmals unbewusst, weil ich nenne den kram, also was ich halt
mache ist, was ich halt ganz gerne mache ist sowas hier, git commit a-m 0w oder so und
dann hab ich es aus Versehen schonmal eingecheckt, das kommt schonmal vorher, ok das müsste jetzt
aber funktionieren, was ich da getrieben hab, so, da müssen wir uns den kram noch merken,
was startet der da, browser, mach das anders, ja wie denn, kann man lounge ohne async machen,
aber ich kann wait machen, ne das gefällt mir auch nicht, aber es wird so funktionieren,
so, page, new page, create, das könnte man tatsächlich machen, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
das könnte man tatsächlich machen, ja, bloß schonmal überlegen, emails an den chef werden
jetzt in twitch language geschrieben, wie gesagt ich hab es schon teilweise geschafft
twitch emotes und so ein plötzchen da reinzuschreiben, so jetzt erstellt er den kram aber
nur einmal, ne, alternate, page content, sollte eigentlich funktionieren, oh, das hab ich jetzt
verkackt, ach natürlich, ok, ihr habt recht, das kann überhaupt nicht funktionieren, guck
mal, das ist ja noch gar nicht fertig, während ich das hier mach, oder, stimmt, ne das kann
halt, das kann so nicht funktionieren, ne das ist natürlich doof, das ist natürlich blöd,
haben wir das jetzt gescheit, ne das kann so nicht funktionieren, kengen ich bin mir
nicht ganz sicher was du meinst, du meinst wahrscheinlich irgendwie sowas, oder, irgendwie
sowas, ne das macht es nicht unleserlich, ich hab da eh so ein komisches, so eine komische
vorliebe, also ich mach das immer so, ich mach kein diss vor irgendwelche klassenvariablen
instanzdinger, so da mach ich underscore, alles was metoden sind, oder, oder irgendwie
großgeschriebene statikdinger oder so, da mach ich immer diss davor, ich kann euch nicht
erklären warum, ich glaub das gibt auch kein coding standard der das nur drinne hat, das
könnte man tatsächlich machen, ja, dass wir das hier drin erstellen, ja das ist eigentlich
gar nicht so schlecht, weil den können wir nämlich auch async machen, massif brainchat
wieder hier, hallo, genau, und da können wir das jetzt nämlich drin erstellen, so, machen
wir nämlich den müll hier raus, das können wir auch raus machen, create async, genau,
oh jetzt sind wir mal ganz korrekt, jetzt sind wir ganz korrekt, jetzt können wir uns bei
microsoft bewerben, wobei microsoft an den graben selber nicht überall hält, ne, ach
so natürlich das funktioniert so nicht, moment, moment, das funktioniert so natürlich nicht,
ich muss sagen new, new, cute chat, und jetzt kann ich das setzen, ne, ah yes, so kengin
wahrscheinlich, sowas in der richtung meinest du denke ich mal, so, website scraper ja, genau,
also machen wir nicht new, cute chat, jetzt können wir noch mehr big brain machen, jetzt
können wir sagen, jetzt machen wir den constructor private, da kann niemand davon was anlegen
außer ich selbst, das ist ja massif brain hier, cute chat parser, create, richtig next level
file fat, nicht search, moment, moment, moment, moment, äh, mach das verkehrt, warte mal,
ich will doch gar keinen task anlegen, ich will einfach nur einen, ach ne, moment, ich
muss, warte mal, ich muss das awaiten, jetzt, cack wait, ja, jetzt, alles klar, ok, jetzt
ist gut, jetzt passt das, also ich hab ein paar, blablabla, da können wir das jetzt
noch auf eine zeile schreiben, da können wir uns wirklich bei microsoft bewerben, danach,
ich hätte das auch mit wait machen können, ja, aber wait, ne, wir sind ja modernes dotnet,
in dem fall, wahrscheinlich wäre wait tatsächlich einfacher gewesen, aber so ist auf jeden
fall mehr c sharp neuniger, ja, search, search, ja das können wir auch noch machen, genau,
ich finde das gar nicht schlecht, ich finde das echt gar nicht übel, ich finde das eigentlich
ganz cool, hat was, ich finde das eigentlich ganz cool, so, aber es geht jetzt ja hier
nicht darum, irgendwie den patternwettbewerb zu gewinnen, ich hab gar keinen constructor,
das darf außer mir keiner aufrufen, so, so, jetzt können wir das mal ausbringen, also,
jetzt brauchen wir die alternate query, das da, und jetzt suchen wir mal nach ryzen 5950x,
ist dotnet auch eine scriptsprache, kommt drauf an, wie du das ganze definierst, so
einen großartigen unterschied gibt es ja da eigentlich mittlerweile, also das ist fließend,
das ist fließend, so sachen wie du früher erzählt hast, so nach dem motto, das eine
ist rein interpretiert und das andere ist rein kompiliert, das ist heute ziemlich fließend
und außerdem, würde ich das an sich gar nicht so unterscheiden, weil letztendlich
unterm strich alles programmiersprachen sind, ich weiß nicht warum das früher gerne leute
unterschieden haben, das hat sich mir immer noch nicht so ganz erschlossen, es wurde
gesagt so nach dem motto, das ist eine programmiersprache und das ist eine scriptsprache, dabei ist
es eigentlich blödsinn, dabei ist jede scriptsprache auch eine programmiersprache, es mag vielleicht
nicht jede programmiersprache eine scriptsprache sein, wenn man sagt, ok, es geht darum, dass
das rein interpretiert wird, aber mal ganz im ernst, was ist denn javascript, das hat
schon script im name, ist javascript eine scriptsprache oder ist javascript, was ist
das, da sieht man schon, dass es heutzutage total unscharf ist, weil javascript ist nicht
rein interpretiert und wenn du python hast, das ist auch was, wo du zu irgendeinem bytecode
kompilieren kannst, genauso wie dotnet, also das ist mittlerweile ziemlich fließend ehrlich
gesagt, der ganze kram und gerade bei javascript sieht man es ganz gut, javascript selber
ist halt absolut big brain mittlerweile, was die bei google da abziehen im hintergrund.
So, also, wir haben jetzt, jetzt muss ich erstmal überlegen, also, wir suchen jetzt
nicht nach 3090 rtx, sondern wir suchen nach ryzen boxed, boxed, was ist typescript, das
wird ja zu javascript kompilt, genau, das siehst du, ich finde, da macht diese Unterschiede
macht eigentlich wenig, macht irgendwie wenig Sinn, das kann man, da muss man sich nicht
so dran aufhängen, ich finde es viel interessanter, was programmierspannen für den ansatz verfolgen,
oder kobol, der chat ist immer noch nicht drüber hinweg über kobol, also ich finde
es viel interessanter, was programmierspannen für den ansatz verfolgen, ob die sagen, hey,
wir machen jetzt so strikt funktionale sachen, oder wir machen so ein multiding, wie beispielsweise
die sharps, die sharps kann ja mittlerweile ansetzen aus allen möglichen richtungen,
es gibt mittlerweile sachen, wo du komplett klötze in den browser zusammenschiebst, so,
also ich muss mir das jetzt erstmal, also wir haben, ok, mach ich den da für einen
kack, ich will nicht, ich will nicht das da haben, ich will, der chat, chat ist schuld,
der chat verwirrt mich, das da will ich haben, xy machen wir mal weg, ich glaube nicht, dass
wir das brauchen, und AMD Ryzen will ich da auch nicht dran stehen haben, sondern irgendein
template, das ich an der stelle dann mal einen suchbegriff einsetzen kann, so, zack, was
hat er jetzt für schmerzen hier, was will er mir sagen, gar nix, ok, gucken wir mal ob
das ganze jetzt läuft, wenigstens, jawoll, funktioniert, so, und jetzt geht er nicht
auf die url alternate, sondern er geht auf die url, die da mit dem passenden suchbegriff,
und der suchbegriff setzt sich dann zusammen aus, string format, meine url, und wird ersetzt
durch meinen suchbegriff, was nicht so ganz stimmt, ich muss das noch eskapen, sowas
in der richtung, dann auch, dass man statt dem artikel nach einem e ansuchen kann, wenn
die suche das unterstützt, dann wird das funktionieren, ja ansonsten nicht, so, und jetzt search,
und jetzt sollte ich eigentlich auf AMD Ryzen, sonst sollte ich den source code bekommen
von dieser suchseite, ok, gibt es, kennt jemand nen schönen konsolen, html, pretty fire oder
sowas, html, tidy, ok, excellent, das brauchen wir, was, ne, ne, ne, das brauchen wir nicht,
will da nix raus machen, ich will einfach nur, dass es schön formatiert, ist da nicht irgendwas
fertiges, oder, how to pretty print html file, oh, das ist ne gute frage, das ist auch wieder
sowas, wo der übergang fließend ist, ich hab noch nicht so ganz verstanden, was ein
framework ist, wo ist der unterschied zur library, wenn ich eine website mit bootstrap
und jquery gebaut habe, hab ich dann mit frameworks gearbeitet oder libraries, das
ist wie gesagt auch, der unterschied ist auch fließend, also ich würde es so definieren
in der richtung, ne library ist ein stück software, was jemand anderes programmiert
hat oder was du programmiert hast zum wiederverwenden, das eine spezielle aufgabe löst, sei es
zum beispiel ne library für textausgabe formatieren oder ne library für irgendwelche sachen berechnen
oder was auch immer, ne library für irgendwelche mathematischen sachen machen oder sonst was,
also sprich, das ist ein abgegrenzter funktionsumfang, die wiederverwendbar eine sache löst, zumindest
nicht eine sache themenspezifisch gut abgegrenzt, guck dir beispielsweise sowas wie opencl
und ne nicht opencl, wie heißt das ding, opencv an, das ist ne library für, nein schwachsinn
nicht opencv, ich muss anders anfangen, opencv ist ein framework mit ganz vielen unterteilen,
die für bildbearbeitung und sowas gedacht sind, so und ein framework ist eigentlich
eher so ne sammlung aus unterschiedlichen libraries, unterschiedlichen funktionen,
was aber ne gewisse ne gewissen weg vorgibt, wie man sachen zu machen hat, so würd ich
das jetzt irgendwie mal mir zusammenreimen, wie gesagt der übergang ist fließend, opencv
würde ich sagen ist eher ne, oder sagen wir mal ffmpeg, ffmpeg ist ein framework zur audio
video bearbeitung, so und ffmpeg setzt sich zusammen aus ganz vielen teilen, ffmpeg hat
zum beispiel nen modul, was sich um upscaling, downscaling kümmert, ffmpeg hat nen modul
mit ganz vielen unterschiedlichen codecs drinnen, ffmpeg hat nen modul für gpu beschleunigung
und solche geschichten, also könnte man sagen ffmpeg ist ein framework, was sich aus unterschiedlichen
modulen schräg-schräg libraries zusammensetzt für bildbearbeitung und ffmpeg hat halt auch
nen gewissen weg oder ne gewisse vorstellung davon, wie du es verwenden sollst, wohingegen
ne library halt dadurch, dass sie thematisch recht gut abgegrenzt ist, eigentlich klar
ist, wie man sie verwenden sollte, zum beispiel was das ist, du hast ne library, die 2 zahlen
zusammenrechnen kann oder die auf 50 verschiedene varianten 2 zahlen oder endlich viele zahlen
was man immer zusammenrechnen kann, dann ist relativ klar, ok, funktionsaufruf a macht
das, funktionsaufruf b macht das, wenn du jetzt allerdings diese sachen miteinander
irgendwie verbinden musst, dann sieht das ganze schon wieder anders aus und bei ffmpeg
ist es zum beispiel so, dass wenn du nen video decodes, dann hat ffmpeg da ne ganz genaue
vorstellung von, wie das intern im speicher aussehen muss, dass beispielsweise der video
encoder das wieder versteht, so und natürlich könntest du sagen, ja ich verwende jetzt
einen video decoder, nen video encoder, dann denke ich mir was eigenes aus, wie ich das
im arbeitsspeicher abbilde und sonst was, könntest du alles machen, bei ffmpeg sieht
es aber so aus, ffmpeg sagt dir, wie du es machen musst, sonst funktioniert es nicht,
ja, so, so ungefähr würde ich das jetzt umschreiben, ja, ich hoffe man konnte damit
was anfangen, war glaube ich ziemlich random gelaber, aber ich hoffe man konnte mir irgendwie
halbwegs folgen, was ich meine, was will das hier eigentlich, ja gut, ok ich hab keine
ahnung ob ich nen ordentlichen html formatter finde, deswegen machen wir jetzt einfach das
mal in visual studio code auf, gucken ob es die richtige seite ist, ah das sieht schon
mal gut aus, also list row, da ist es doch, guck mal, list row, das ist da ist er, amd
boxed, da haben wir ihn, da haben wir ihn, ok und das heißt, wenn ich die seite jetzt
im chrome aufmache, dann müsste das auch mehr oder weniger die alternate seite sein von
der, ja, halt ohne css und alles, aber es ist die alternate seite mit der suche, die
wir hier auf haben, ok das ist schon mal gut, das funktioniert, jetzt können wir gucken
ob das mit diesem query selector funktioniert, ob man da jetzt den kram rausbekommt, ups,
nein nein, run, meine backtaste funktioniert nicht, ah, ich glaube ich weiß warum, ah
jetzt, exellent, gucken ob das mit dem list row klappt, ja tatsächlich, nice, oder auch
nicht, ja, hab ich, hab ich, root byte, achso, moment, sorry ich hab nur den anfang gelesen,
also das hab ich schon verwendet, das hab ich noch nicht gemacht, das haben wir sogar
im stream verwendet, für, ich glaub, webseiten zum ausliefern schon, nee, das haben wir
im stream verwendet, kann sich noch einer da dran erinnern, moment, twitter, moment wo
ist mein media, moment, ich poste ja so viele bildchen, wo ist es, moment, kann sich noch
jemand hier dran erinnern, haben wir auch zusammen im stream gemacht, so, und das bild
kam glaube ich vom spiff filesystem, wenn ich mich noch recht erinnere, ok, wie bekommt
man den jetzt, content, ich bin zu doof dafür das pappertierding zu verwenden, also, ich
brauch mal, ich brauch mal ein beispiel davon, ich will mir jetzt im endeffekt rausholen,
das erste list row, so, was kann ich damit jetzt machen, query selector async, runs,
if no element matched, return value ist 0, ok, und was kann ich jetzt mit diesem handle
machen, wie komm ich da jetzt an den kram, returns adjacent representation of the object,
will ich das, das will ich nicht, hast du schon mal das problem gehabt, dass spiffs
deprecated ist, nee, also lass mal überlegen, was will ich jetzt eigentlich, ich will jetzt
jetzt das erste element haben und dann da drunter, stock status, ja, chat, jetzt brauchen wir
big brain css logik, gucken wir mal, wie ging das in css so, oder so, dass ich eben gesagt
hab, ok ich will das nächste element was da drunter ist, war das so, ok anscheinend war
das richtig, weil so wirds nicht folgt, so bedeutet glaub ich folgt direkt danach, ja,
ok, css logik, ok und jetzt, wie kann ich mir das jetzt ausgeben lassen, get, get property
async, what the fuck, wie kann ich mir das jetzt ausgeben lassen, gibt es text wenigstens,
text, nee get, kann ich das nicht einfach printen lassen, einfach das html element ausgeben
lassen, alter wie verwendet man das, ok, get text, moment, das müssen wir jetzt mal query
selektor, get text, how to get text from element, exellent, ich bin nicht der einzige der den
kram da, what the fuck, was, jason value, was machen die da für dinger, was für dinger,
jason value, ok ich mach das jetzt einfach mal, mal gucken was da rauskommt, kein plassen
schimmer, ok sehr gut, jetzt weiß ich voll Bescheid, jetzt alles klar, what the hell,
wer soll das denn, achso, das ist ja auch kein java script, wow, achso await, wonks,
alter hör mal auf, ok das geht so nicht, ich hab keine Ahnung wie das funzt, ich muss
doch einfach mal den text von ausgeben lassen können, breakpoint setzen, das ist tatsächlich
ne gute ide, das machen wir jetzt, breakpoint, fuck, ach nee, moment, der hängt hier an
der Stelle, nee nee nee, warte mal, breakpoint, machs einfach mit node.js, ja das bringt mir
ja nix, so also was da drinnen, ich verwende den debugger von rider normalerweise so gut
wie nie, hier, da, was ist da drille, element handle, page, monkaS, alter was ist das, ok
da ist schonmal nix drin was wir einfach so verwenden können, das wäre jetzt auch zu
einfach wenn man da jetzt irgendwie den text von rauskriegen könnte, wir hätten es doch
in kobol machen sollen Leute, nee page, page ist die ganze seite, das bringt nix, page
ist die ganze seite, kobol hätte alles einfacher gemacht, ja oder gleich in abab, sap, ok
nee nee, siehste, das verwenden wir, dass wir verwenden das falsch, ah guck mal es gibt
auch query, query selector all, es gibt auch query selector all, das heißt da kriegen
wir jetzt, ah wenn ich das mache, das ist natürlich, das ist auch mal ganz spannend,
das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken, dann krieg ich alle, dann krieg ich alle, warte mal
hier count, das müsste ja dann ein paar sein, ok alternate hat uns noch nicht gesperrt,
man weiß ja nie, ah wie krieg ich denn jetzt hier den text raus, kann doch nicht so schwierig
sein, guck mal ich kann sogar nen screenshot davon machen, warum krieg ich nicht einfach
mal den text, cack wait, um nur zu pappertier, na angle sharp bringt mir ja nix, ich brauch
ja erstmal das html zeug, achso warum ich pappertier verwende, das liegt daran, weil
die seiten nicht unbedingt scharf darauf sind gepasst zu werden und man mit nem echten
browser besser fährt, gerade wenn die später anfangen dann noch irgendwelche sachen zu
checken und cookies zu setzen, dass man auf die suchseite kommt und sowas, da brauch ich
nen vollständigen browser, ich will doch einfach nur dieses element als text, alter wobei,
ja doch ich will den text, warte mal wir machen das anders, ich will den text haben, ich will
das hier haben, so ich will den text, das da steht, liefertermin unbekannt und ich will
den titel haben und der titel ist product link, der titel ist amd ryzenbox, ok, was
machen wir jetzt, also, product link, alter ich bin da zu doof für, das kann ja jetzt
sein, monkaS, stock status, weil das doch auch gehen müsste, get property, das wollte
ich jetzt ausprobieren, das wollte ich jetzt danach ausprobieren, ich das hab, genau, get
property, async title, so in der richtung, hab ich mir das auch gedacht, ja, kann man
dem kram nicht irgendeinen timeout mitgeben, wann der, wann der, dass der nicht so ewig
hängt, wenn er es nicht findet, das ist doch gut, da haben wir es doch, amd ryzen 9,9,5,000
euro boxed, genau das brauchen wir, übrigens das mit title stimmt so gar nicht, was gibt
das da alles für 30 milliarden dinge zurück, ok, da können wir jetzt schonmal ein neues
objekt anlegen, product info, ne, das nennen wir nicht name, das heißt wirklich titel,
ok, nicht auf jeden fall nicht title, sondern, kann man da drauf zugreifen, krieg ich jetzt
da, krieg ich jetzt da nur diesen wert da hinten raus, ne, ne, ne, ne, der hat ja schon
drauf gewartet, das ist, das ist irgendeinen js handle objekt, so und ich will jetzt einfach
nur den text da raus bekommen, text get, vielleicht, vielleicht echt to string, das glaub ich
aber nicht, das macht der unter der haube schon, ne, ne, text, das nicht, jason value,
ein plassen schimmer, was ich da eigentlich mache grad, ah, alles klar, ok, warum geht
das jetzt, ich hab keine ahnung warum es geht, aber es funktioniert, alles klar, ok, easy,
kann ich da irgendwie nur angeben, dass ich das halt string haben will, oh, geht auch,
ok, das ist bestimmt nicht the way das zu machen, aber es funktioniert, product info,
ok, titel, das da, sehr gut, mal gucken ob das jetzt auch funktioniert, was ich da mach,
to string wäre zu einfach gewesen, das darf nicht, das kann nicht einfach so funktionieren,
ok, wunderbar, wunderbar, genau so brauchen wir das, genau so brauchen wir das, so jetzt
haben wir den titel am start, was brauchen wir denn sonst noch, ich mein, wie gesagt
wir können jetzt nichts alternate spezifisches machen, weil das soll ja andere shopseiten
auch auslesen können, wir brauchen den link auf die produktseite, den brauchen wir auf
jeden fall, hier, wo ist der link zur produktseite, sieht denn jemand, ah, hier, da, ok, das
heißt ich muss noch href auch noch rausholen, link, Leute warum sind noch so viele, so viele
am start, ist ja der wahnsinn, danach probieren wir das ganze mit minefactory noch aus, guck
mal hier, da ist er doch, so, wenn wir das jetzt öffnen, copy link, dann kommen wir
direkt auf der produktpage raus, excellent, wieso nicht nachmachen, weil alternate und
generell webseiten das nicht mögen, wenn sie gepasst werden, zumal die leute es teilweise
auch übertreiben und dann sekundenweise da abfragen, so, also jetzt haben wir den link,
auch gut, das habe ich ganz vergessen, das brauchen wir nämlich auf jeden fall hier
auch noch, link, link, dann müssen wir das da draus machen, sonst klappt das wieder nicht,
wie gesagt ich habe keinen platzen schimmer, wie man das richtig macht, das funktioniert
einfach, link, streamst du mit 48 fps, ja, achso passt, alles klar, was brauchen wir jetzt,
was brauchen wir dann sonst noch, is available, ja, das muss ich noch irgendwie rauskriegen,
wie kriege ich das hier raus, liefertermin unbekannt, wieso nennst du dich ja eigentlich
nicht max fps, weil ich mir den account angelegt habe, bevor ich überhaupt selbst streamen
wollte und dann habe ich den account einfach weiter benutzt und jetzt finde ich es eigentlich
ganz cool und jetzt lasse ich so, in welchen intervallen willst du die webseite scrapen,
nicht so oft, keine ahnung, alle 5 minuten mal abfragen oder so, also nix was denen irgendwie
nennenswert, das stresst, man kann sich umbenennen, ja ich habe sogar das originale max fps registriert
auf twitch, immer noch urlaub, ja heute ist der letzte tag, morgen muss ich wieder arbeiten,
schau mal oben in der url, da hat es y gleich 0, ja, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung,
was das bedeuten soll, es geht nämlich auch ohne, richtig pains champ, ich habe auch echt
keinen bock, aber ich sage es euch wie es ist, überhaupt keinen bock, so product link,
jetzt haben wir das da, ah details, na gut die details jucken mich nicht, das ist egal,
das sollen sich die leute dann schon gefälligst auf der seite selbst angucken, details brauchen
wir nicht zum durchsuchen, zumal das auf jeder seite anders ist, nee nee, ich werde dann
so eine übersicht machen, also ich werde dann einfach so die 8 gängigsten seiten durchsuchen
nach amd ryzen 5950x und jeweils die ergebnisse mit dem überlegen stock anzeigen, was ich
jetzt noch brauche ist wirklich das hier, stock status brauche ich, stocks ja, vielleicht
soll ich das übrigens mal richtig nennen, nee komm wir nennen, wir sind toll wenn das
jetzt z, ich will einfach erstmal gucken wie es funktioniert, stock status container, so
finden tut er den kram ja, haben wir ja schon gesehen, oder auch nicht, wann time outet
das eigentlich, ich meine irgendwann muss das doch mal time outen, wenn das nicht findet
und wo geht man, wo geht man, man muss dem ding doch irgendeinen time out angeben können,
set timeout get property inner text okay das ist natürlich eine gute idee
ja ja war skript kurs ja wo hängt er denn jetzt wieder das wird scheiß eben ging es
noch ich muss dem ding in den timeout eingeben können das soll das soll immer ein bisschen
entspannen ich mache genau ich mache den stock checker bot exakt so sieht es aus genau so
sieht es aus get inner text jason value of air ja das probieren wir jetzt aus ich weiß
nicht warum der hier umspackt was hallo max wenn man ein feier tablet routet sollten doch alle
android apps darauf funktionieren oder ja außer die amazon dinger die amazon dinger haben damit
ein problem es kann aber jetzt also wie gesagt kann sein dass es funktioniert das problem ist
dass die amazon apps das login vom feier tablet verwenden also das in feier OS integrierte login
und nicht das amazon app login wenn du es auf einem feier tablet verwendest und das will man
ja normalerweise nicht das packt rum weil du er geschrieben hast habe ich schon die ganze zeit
schon warum hängt das denn jetzt ich darf das wahrscheinlich einfach nicht so oft starten
no sandbox nie warum soll ich no sandbox setzen aber ich könnte tatsächlich hier
oben ein timeout setzen wenn man dann ein timeout setzen kann achso das ist wie lang man wartet um
zu starten ja das können wir das hast du mal vor er getestet ne okay aber warum soll ich die
sandbox disablen was macht man hier args ne wie gibt man das an args aber das eine hatte mit
dem anderen schon mal gar nichts aber so disabel gpu ist auf jeden fall ok kann man das kann man
das mit den args dann einfach so machen ne oder ne ach ne man muss das einzeln machen
man muss das einzeln machen
so dann wie gesagt die args bringen ja also ich hätte erstmal nix
so ok also wie kriege ich denn jetzt diesen müll da raus das kann auch nicht so kompliziert
sein ich will den aktuellen stock status rausbekommen stock status available ah warte mal moment das ist
doch ganz einfach wie ich das rauskrieg available stock moment da steht ja sogar in der css klasse
drin das heißt wenn das available stock ist das doch noch viel einfacher wenn das available stock
ist wenn das available stock ist wenn da was drinne steht dann ist es available und wenn
das nicht drinne steht ist es nicht da ganz einfach moment was also info titel funktioniert
nicht mehr was wenn fünfzeite lieferzeit dran steht das müssen wir tatsächlich mal gucken auf
lager auf lager haben die noch so für dinger lager auf lager unbekannt die haben nur auf lager
und unbekannter hier available clarification also wir machen einfach den umkehrschluss wenn dort
nicht available stock steht dann ist es erst lief aber in fünf tagen und sonstwüns interessiert
uns nicht das ist doch ok problem ist kann ich hier in er weiter querien sehr gut sehr gut das
funktioniert ok dann habe ich doch jetzt alles das heißt wenn ich jetzt hier mal gucke testen
was mal umgedreht da ist jetzt available available unsure dann müsste das jetzt ausgeben warum
nicht nachmachen weil das die seiten nicht mögen das funktioniert nicht ich gehe hier
um auf product link das kann nicht funktionieren ok also item also wie gesagt die seiten mögen
das in der regel nicht wenn man ihr in webs ihre webseite passt und ich habe kein bock drauf das
ist 30 millionen leute anfangen alternate zu passen just for fun das ist list wir nennen es
einfach mal so wie es ist list row da müssen wir das weg machen oder link select ist das
eigentlich für den unterschied select also jetzt filtern wir den kram mal raus ich hoffe das
funktioniert jetzt was ich da mache mal gucken ob das jetzt tut hoffentlich geht das was ich
da getrieben habe was ist gleich noch mal rückgängig schema punkt org standard zu verwenden
ach echt das ist ja cool wenn das ganze mehr als schema punkt org standard zu verwenden alternate
und mein für die haben beispielsweise auf jeder produktseite elemente mit dem art in
gut item prop wenn du das alles lokal machst dann ist das kein problem allerdings lokal
wirst du ja nicht rauskriegen ob mein factory alternate oder sonst wäre eine cpu in stock haben
auf der produktzeit ok da müsste ich mir aber vorher erstmal die ganzen produktseiten
raussuchen aber die idee ist auf jeden fall pock das werde ich mir mal kurz speichern das
heißt also nur mal das können wir gleich mal überprüfen das würde also quasi heißen wenn
wir jetzt auf eine produktseite gehen also zum beispiel zum beispiel da drauf und uns mal den
source code angucken ja wo ist er blöd jetzt sind sie immer da und was müsste dann da stehen meta
item prop
availability müsste dann da stehen aha guck mal da
arian zwei monat dankeschön für den sub huge subscription dankeschön
ach so
ach das ist ja cool
und wozu gibt so was also die werden sich doch nicht ernsthaft alle an
irgendwie einen ähnlichen standard halten das wäre doch irgendwie ganz untypisch
gsante so 17 monate das ist ja schon hyper subscription hier 17 monate massiv
für den sub
so steht das steht das auch steht das auch in der übersichtseite drin da müssen wir jetzt mal kurz
gucken ne da steht nicht drin ok in der übersichtseite aber das ist auf jeden fall gut zu wissen
ne ne geiz über geiz als bringt es nix geiz halt ist es viel zu langsam aber das ist geil das das
ist gut zu wissen also ich glaube da kann man auf jeden fall was mit anfangen mit hauptsächlich
für suchmaschinen verwendet ja da bräuchte ich halt die produktseite aber das ist kein problem
da würde ich einmalig eine suche machen mir die produktseiten merken und dann immer auf
der produktseite direkt gucken so aber wie dem auch sei das ist gute gute sache also das ist das ist
echt gut zu wissen so und jetzt gucken wir mal dass wir noch den den status rauskriegen stock
war das ist
müsste das finden eigentlich
kann mir einer pasen erklären er gut pasen das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so ganz das korrekte
wort aber was damit gemeint ist ist du hast einen text der irgendwas aussagen sollte also wo
irgendwelche informationen drin stecken in dem text ja und um diese informationen aus dem text
rauszukriegen musst du sie pasen also das hier ist ja im endeffekt nichts anderes wie ein langer
text da stecken aber zum beispiel informationen drinne wie item ist verfügbar oder nicht so und
wenn ich mir aus diesem text die informationen rausholen die ich brauche dann ist das quasi
rauspasen aber das mit den textes habe ich schon nie gesehen das ist wirklich praktisch warum
nicht nachmachen weil die seiten das nicht mögen keine shop anbieter haben es gern wenn man ihre
seiten passt ja kofax vielleicht mache ich das so in der richtung so als available anschauen
ist jetzt hat er gefunden und jetzt gibt es available stock check ich das findet er nicht
und wenn er das nicht findet nice so also if jetzt null oder was ist das jetzt was da rauskommt
oder empty string oder was auch immer an null ok das heißt ich kann das einfach testen ok ist
natürlich nice hat sich das quasi jetzt schon mal erledigt available so wenn das gleich gleich
null ist dann ist es auch dann ist es not available also muss man um gleich null gucken und jetzt
können wir hier gucken ist available gleich das so und jetzt haben wir alle infos die wir brauchen
das doch praktisch jetzt haben wir jetzt haben wir den den name vom produkt den link zur produktseite
und ob es verfügbar ist oder nicht genau das was wir brauchen ja ich glaube in der aktuellen
zeit machen das viele weil alle hardware kaufen wollen und nicht auf die reihe bekommen warten
und klicken nachts um vier hat auch keiner bock drauf preis ja ja klar den preis brauche ich
natürlich auch noch den preis brauche ich natürlich auch noch so ist ein sternchen
dahinter weil man immer ein sternchen dahinter ist wahrscheinlich also price price muss noch
aus paar paar sorn so also available lister available ok price price ist lister query selektor
price ob was findet ist auch ein schema orc element ja das problem ist hier an der stelle
habe ich noch kein schema orc schema orc habe ich erst auf der detail seite und ich will jetzt
nicht die detail seiten auch gleich noch mit aufmachen weil da muss man ja alles doppelt
und dreifach machen so ist das ein request und ansonsten müsste ich aus einem request 50 requests
machen so nach dem motto also das lasse ich erst einmal wie gesagt ich will den ja nicht
irgendwie mehr traffic machen als nötig bei altern muss du noch darauf achten dass sich die
preis text ändern ja aber es wird wahrscheinlich alles es wird wahrscheinlich alles auf auch
weiterhin den preis stehen aber wahrscheinlich sind die ist es sind sie dann rot oder so ne
sagen wir tages deals gucken uns das doch mal an price ach so kann man hier nach deals suchen
oder ist der preis das sieht eigentlich ziemlich ziemlich gleich aus ach du meinst hier unten
drunter das weil er sonst wie steht stadt ich glaube das ist egal weil der rote das was da
in rot steht das hier interessant ist und danach bauen wir mein factory ein ok price price hat
er gefunden so und wie krieg ich da jetzt get property und jetzt was inner text oder was wie
kriege ich den text raus von einem element kann er zu kompliziert sein keck weight ha easy da ist
es doch das war jetzt einfach ja du hast recht tatsächlich
das ist auch das sternchen dahinter gut auf das sternchen sternchen kann ich verzichten
das brauche ich nicht aber bei alt ist immer ein prinzipiell immer ein sternchen dahinter
und es ist auch prinzipiell immer punktstrich die haben nix in cent in cent beträgen weil dann
lösche ich nehme ich den ganzen mist der hinten dran ist
ja ne der lösche ich nehme ich den ganzen mist der da hinten dran ist da kann ich da auch
ein int raus machen weil so ist so müsste ich da jetzt halt den text und text ist für price
ziemlich doof weil ich will ja später checken können ob da kram über 800 euro ist oder unter
800 euro das brauche ich schon als zahl und nicht so als komisches was auch immer das da ist
ok so ja price text so und wie kriegt man den kram jetzt da raus
boah das ist halt schon echt abartig hässlich aber mein gut was willst du machen
weil es ist ja gar kein text gibt kein help nee was willst du denn wissen text und da
müsste jetzt der ups habe ich jetzt verkehrt gemacht achso ja und da müsste jetzt einfach
nur der text drinne stehen wenn ich es richtig sehe
ok das brauche ich dann gar nicht will er jetzt von mir
einfach so
alle alle die bedienung von dem ding ist aber auch echt ätzend ist ja was jetzt machen
also
Jason
Ah
Wait
Ah ja ok ok jetzt passt das
Ich glaub ich hab mich vorher einfach nur verschrieben
Ok wunderbar
So jetzt haben wir den Text
Und jetzt jetzt ok ja
Jetzt können wir mal gucken wir können diesen Range Selector jetzt verwenden
Kann man Range Selector in Text mittlerweile verwenden?
Geht das?
Ja also sprich wir wollen oh fuck wie ist das jetzt wir wollen ab dem ab dem zweiten ab
dem dritten nee ab dem geht das bei null los
Ab dem zweiten Element bis zum vorletzten Element
Also wenn das jetzt funktioniert dann beiß ich mir in Arsch
Es funktioniert es funktioniert ernsthaft
Ich muss da am Ende noch ein riesen Try Catch drumherum machen weil es ja zu jeder Zeit
abkacken kann ja
Kann zu jeder Zeit abscheißen wenn irgendwas in der Seite geändert wird
Das ist neu das gibt es glaube ich seit C-Sharp 7 oder 8
Aber das ist nice ne
So und jetzt muss ich den Kram nehmen
Kann man ein Int parsen aus einer Zahl mit einem Punkt drinnen?
Ich glaube das macht den verrückt weil dann braucht der nämlich Ländereinstellungen was
der Punkt bedeutet ob das jetzt ein Komma ist oder ob das ein Tausender Trennzeichen
ist oder was auch immer
Ich glaube ich lösche den Punkt lieber
Ich glaube ich werfe den Punkt lieber raus
Ja ist auf jeden Fall besser
Ich kann jetzt in dem Fall von alternate automatisch abfragen ob es
Horizon CPUs verfügbar hat
Marsch jetzt noch für Mine Factory
Int
Trial
Pass
Wie ging das noch mal so und jetzt war out
Ne Sekunde Out war Price
Ich hab so viel Prices da blickt ja keiner mehr durch
Price Element
Ok wunderbar
Price in Int alles klar
Hübsch ist was anderes aber es funktioniert
Die andere Seite ne wir machen kein Tri Pass
Wir machen ein Pass weil ich will das das abkackt
Ich will das das abkackt wenn es nicht geht
Weil was will ich mit der Info machen wenn der Preis nicht da ist
Ja das soll einfach abkacken
Ok dann brauchen wir hier noch ein Dings für den Preis
Preis
Ach ich habs Pass kann ich Price ich kack noob
Ok top funktioniert
Alles klar ok nice das gefällt mir ok
Also search Async, Async, QChat Paser sehr gut
Return
Product
Ne
Info
Alles klar
Das ist nice das gefällt mir ok
Das heißt das gibt mir jetzt immer das erste zurück was ja auch ok ist
Ich muss halt genau suchen nach was ich suche ja also muss ich halt genau wissen
Nice cool
Ok jetzt sollten wir das vielleicht mal gescheit benennen
Weil als nächstes ist jetzt mal Mind Factory dran
Wie man da was auslesen kann mal gucken
Oder was wollen wir als nächstes machen Leute
Mind Factory oder Case King oder
So dann machen wir jetzt mal ordentlich alternate Paser
Otto Otto ok
Deutsche Otto LAN ja machen wir Otto Alter
Otto wir sind gepasst
Otto.de
Unterwäsche Grill RTX ne ne Ryzen
Haben die überhaupt sowas
5950 x
Ne hörst du mal die haben sowas gar nicht bei Otto
Kack noobs
Ja doch
Ist das nicht ein bisschen umständlich ja schon aber das kannst du es nicht anders
machen
Die Seiten haben keine öffentlichen Apis
Ok Leute jetzt parsen wir Otto
Hallo Otto ich will in 5 tau
Otto sagt mir gibt es nicht
Ok die Seite sagt ich glaube die will ich nicht
Ne
90 RTX
Otto sagt nein ja
Was sind das eigentlich für Crap PCs die die da anbieten
Die haben gar keine einzelnen Hardware kann das sein
Ich glaube die haben gar kein Zeug Einzel
Ja das sagt da muss ich auch nichts ausprobieren jetzt
Ups wow wow wow wow
Übrigens warum mache ich das eigentlich so kompliziert passt mal auf
Macht das nicht so wie ich sondern macht das ordentlich
Geht da drauf sagt Refactor
Hallo
Refactor rename
Und macht das richtig und nicht so komisch wie ich
Otto ist Boomer versandt ja
Otto hat bis sie sich jetzt da irgendwie die wurden ja glaube ich auch verkauft oder
so
Die haben glaube ich bis zum Schluss
Und auch den meisten das meiste Geld mit Katalogen gemacht habe ich gelesen
So also der alternate Paser ist am Start
Dann machen wir jetzt da aus dieser aus dem da doch ein Interface
Was wir dann iSearch oder irgendwie sowas nennen
Da fällt jetzt gerade nichts anderes ein aber nur dass wir den gleichen Kram wiederverwenden
können
Cute Search
Was ist das denn das ist das ist ein Headless Chrome den wir fernsteuern mit Puppet hier
Ich habe noch eine andere Idee wir brauchen noch diesen Kram immer also diese Sache mit
Ähm
Erstellen von dem Chromium Fenster und so das brauchen wir doch immer
Und das nicht in irgendeine Base Glass rauswursten oder so
Aber dann geht unsere Bigframe Create Methode nicht mehr weil die Static ist
Da muss man sich was anderes überlegen
Dann machen wir das so
Kommen wir mal ob der Kram dann auch funktioniert
Dann machen wir das doch nicht über so eine komische Create
Ich hätte jetzt gesagt wir machen das wirklich ganz ganz billig
Wir machen hier einfach einen Weight rein
Bevor wir jetzt den großen Patternwettbewerb starten
Machen das hier einfach weg
Kann man?
Einfach mal einen Weight rein
Mag jetzt zwar vielleicht nicht schön sein
Ich mache jetzt vielleicht nicht die feine feine Art der C Sharp 9 Programmierung sein
aber es funktioniert
Dann machen wir blocken wir halt zweimal
Mal gucken ob das jetzt klappt
Achso
Was ist das Ziel?
Das Ziel ist das ich sehe sobald was verfügbar ist
Ist available und das sagt er mir jetzt Pauls wenn alles funktioniert
Jawoll
Also alternate hat aktuell kein Ryzen 5050x am Start
Mal gucken wenn ich nach was anderem suche
Aber nachdem er das erste nimmt das beste was er in der Suche findet dann ist Pauls
Das muss ich dann später eh noch ein bisschen umbauen
Wenn ich nämlich nach Grafikkarten suche
Dann muss ich die ganzen Grafikkarte hier alle auf einmal rausholen
Lässt du das ganze dann lokal bei dir laufen?
Ja
Das erste Mal schon
So und jetzt könnten wir so eine Aplik abstract
Klar ist kein parser base oder irgendwie sowas machen
Schmeißen dieses komische Interface wieder weg
Hier das jetzt protected, das mache ich so selten
Protected
Achso und dann kommt der ganze Müll hier rein
Was meckert er jetzt rum?
Quatsch
Machst du das um die Sachen billig zu kaufen?
Ich mache das um die Sachen überhaupt mal zu kaufen
Ich will mir schon seit über einem Jahr einen neuen Rechner kaufen
Und ich sehe es nicht ein dass ich da 1000 Euro mehr ausgebe als notwendig ist
Im Zweifelsfall warte ich auch noch ein paar Monate
Das ist mir egal
Aber ich sehe es nicht ein jetzt so viel mehr Kohle auszugeben
Hier und das hier müssen wir jetzt sagen
Oh das mache ich jetzt wirklich selten
Aber wie macht man das jetzt?
Aplik abstract dass es überschrieben werden muss
So oder?
Sagen wir parser base
Jetzt muss ich sagen overrides
Ich glaube jetzt stimmt das was ich da getrieben habe
Oh 1ks, nein stimmt nicht
Was habe ich jetzt falsch gemacht Leute?
Haha keck
Ja
Was meckert er?
Das ist ja was das habe ich mir jetzt verguckt
Keck wait
Ah Moment ich habe das überschrieben ich kann nur
Ah funktioniert ok
Alles klar
Ja gut funktioniert
Wozu brauchen wir einen neuen PC?
Naja weil ich alles das was ich mache nicht auf der Konsole machen kann außer spielen
Ich kann keine Videos rendern, ich kann keine Videos aufnehmen, ich kann keine Videos schneiden
Ich kann einige Sachen nicht spielen
Pass of Exile ist auf der Playstation naja
Und auf dem PC ist es POG
Also ich kann keine VMS laufen lassen auf der Konsole
Ich kann keine Cobalt Streams machen, ich kann nicht live streamen
Der Tom Laksa hast du was mit Ben Laksa zu tun?
Falls ihr noch irgendjemand kennt
Der Tier Erklärungsexperte oder wie auch immer was es da für Dinger gab
Aber Ben Laksa Beste
Der war das war der beste
Das war das erste dort in dem seinen Videos
Da ist das erste Video wo ich jemals gesehen habe das Katja Grasawitz oder so mit dabei
war
Mir ist es vollkommen egal was die macht
Aber das war das erste Video wo die mal rumgesprungen ist
Zwischen irgendwelchen Mülltonnen
Der Teppichbodenexperte und sowas genau
Was Mixer wie habt ihr es denn jetzt von Mixer?
Achso Mixer Stream
Jaja ne Mixer
Also den einzigen Leuten denen das was gebracht hat mit Mixer gelten mir sicher was eigentlich
Ninja und Shroud
Die haben richtig Kohle gemacht
Erstmal easykohle in Millionen abgegriffen und dann so ok Plattform dich gemacht
Die haben dann nicht ne
Du bist der Quellkodverschönerungsexperte
So den brauchen wir ja der ist wichtig
Der bin ich auch grad ich bin auch grad Quellkodverschönerungsexperte
Alter was will das mir denn hier noch alles erzählen?
Warum soll ich das jetzt rename?
Das kann einfach aufhören zu nerven
Ich hoffe du machst auch Unit Tests immer
Ihr wisst doch ich hab schon immer die Unit Tests fertig
Bevor ich überhaupt anfange
Benutzt doch ein Interface
Ja ich wollte dir eigentlich grad drauf antworten
Da kann ich doch keine Implementierung rein machen aber das stimmt ja gar nicht
Mittlerweile geht das ja
Flo 129
Das würde theoretisch schon Sinn machen
Das Problem ist nur
Das so Seiten wie Idealo und Geizhals und so die sind langsamer
Und ich wills ja schnell wissen
Ich frag direkt bei alternate ab und sobald das Ding verfügbar ist
Dann machen alle meine Lautsprecher im Haus
Dann weiß ich ich muss jetzt sofort hochrennen was einkaufen
Das stimmt der Browser geht da gar nicht rein ja
So ne das passt schon jetzt machen wir noch mal schnell minefactory
Da sind noch mal minefactory gepasst
Da können sie sich nicht beschweren dass wir nur alternate machen
Sofort kaufen wenn GPU unter 800 Euro fällt ja
So machen wir das
Das machen die Lautsprecher wirklich na klar was meinst du denn
So minefactory parsern
Also wie siehts denn da aus wenn man da sucht nach wo ist überhaupt die Suche in minefactory
Da
Was nach was suchen wir da jetzt
Ryzen haben die Autocomplete
Wir suchen da einfach mal genau das gleiche und mal gucken was wir finden
Ja Fonst wurde auch nicht
Ja haben die haben die bei minefactory kein oder was
Haben die sowas nicht
Ja gut das ist ja das ist für meine Zwecke auch vollkommen in Ordnung
Dann weiß ich einfach dass es keinen gibt
Musst du unten in der Liste schauen in welcher Liste muss ich unten schauen
Ansicht umstellen
Ach so du meinst quasi ich muss hier in die Liste
Und dann
Geben wir mal Hardware
Prozessor
Und oder oder Listen die hier auch nur wenn es verfügbar ist
Also hier auch nur wenn es verfügbar ist das heißt man hat gar keine Chance die
Die Detailseite zu finden
Verstehe okay
Ja gut es ist für mich jetzt auch kein Problem weil
Wenn er es nicht findet dann ist halt einfach nicht verfügbar
Was glaubst du ist wichtiger für den Def Obsler von morgen
Das ist Big Brain Frage
Pilsen oder Golang
Bisschen drauf an was du machst
Es ist nicht verkehrt beides zu können
Wobei Pilsen ziemlich ziemlich universell ist
Go ist eher sowas wo ziemlich beliebt ist bei ganzen Kubernetes Cloud und Cloudgedöns
Das ist fast alles in Go programmiert
Aber nachdem er zum größten Teil eh nur irgendwelche Webrequest macht
Gegen irgendwelche Services
Und es meistens
Libraries gibt für die gebräuchlichsten Sachen für die für alle möglichen Sprachen
Also wenn du jetzt keine Ahnung irgendwelche AWS Geschichten oder Azure Geschichten machst
Die kannst du in Pilsen machen in.NET oder in Bash oder in sonst was
Da macht die Sprache nicht so großartig aus
Ich würde es eher danach ausrichten
Wenn ich im Gebiet nicht unterwegs bin oder ob es irgendwelche Libraries nur für Go gibt
Zum Beispiel ich habe hier so eine Videoüberwachung Software mal gebastelt auch hier teilweise
im Stream
Da habe ich Go einen Teil davon in Go verwendet
Weil es einfach eine Library gab die es sonst für nichts anderes gibt
Aber für Go
Ja ich finde die Go Syntax auch nicht schön
Ganz ehrlich
Also man kann das zwar lesen aber Go wirkt so wie so eine
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen von der Syntax her wie C++ Lite so schlimm ist es natürlich
nicht
Aber alleine hast du irgendwie drei verschiedene Varianten
Hast du irgendwie eine Variable zu deklarieren und sowas macht es auch nicht gerade
Schön
Go bekommt jetzt aber Generics habe ich mir sagen lassen
Ich weiß gar nicht wie es damit aussieht
Ist wahrscheinlich immer noch nicht da
Ach ey ist das immer noch da diskutieren die seit zwei Jahren schon wieder rum
Dortnet hat das glaube ich seit 2.0 oder so
Benutzst du Wim?
Ja aber nicht zum Programmieren
Zumindest nicht für solche Sachen
Sondern wenn ich schnell Sachen editieren muss benutze ich Wim
Leute mein Brain ist glaube ich gerade immer in der Lage weiterzumachen gescheit
Einmal 5.800 haben sie
Ey Mr.
Ami wie sieht es aus spielen wir noch eine Runde Battlefield
Ist das Cute Squad wieder am Start
Ich gehe aber vorher was essen
Ja aber ich wollte es mal ausprobieren wie gesagt mit Alternate über Puppetier passen
Das hat ja ganz gut funktioniert
Ich muss mir da aber auf jeden Fall noch Gedanken machen wie ich das am besten aufbaue
Weil die Sache ist die
Wenn ich mich ja nicht darauf verlassen kann dass er findet
Da hat das mal auf GitHub hoch
Also jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht vor
Weil ich habe kein Bock dass dann irgendjemand von so einem Shop sich bei mir aufregt
Nach dem Motto hier die Leute spammen unsere Seite voll
Ja war es aber ein bisschen
Privat Repo kann man
Ich kann dir das auch einfach mal Paste Bin rein machen
Hier Paste Bin
Wenn du es haben willst Paste Bin zack
Warum nicht
Paste Bin easy
Die Sharp Syntax
Unlisted
Paste Bin
Oder willst du es über Post Bin nicht haben
Mach doch einen Gist
Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Idee ich weiß gar nicht ob ich hier angelockt bin
Nein das habt ihr alle nicht gesehen
Gist GitHub
Bin ich hier eingelockt
Hey ich bin eingelockt
Check wie
So zack
Oh
Kann man eben auch sagen
Pylename Extension.cs
Secret Gist
Public Gist
Oh guck mal wir machen ein Secret Gist
Oh Secret Gist
Top Secret Gist
Hat es jetzt eigentlich Syntax Highlighting gehabt
Gist alles klar
Da kommt keiner auf die Idee das irgendwie Gist auszusprechen weil das bedeutet ja auch
ein bisschen was anderes
Hier Leute ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wie ich das am besten mache
Ich kann mich ja nicht darauf verlassen dass die Suche was zurück gibt
Und es ist die Frage wie entscheide ich ob in der Suche was richtiges drin steht oder
nicht
Weil die Seiten können die Sachen entweder als AMD Ryzen
Als Ryzen AMD
AMD Ryzen 9
5.950x AMD Ryzen oder wie auch immer Listen
Gar nicht so einfach
Was benutzt du denn um die Seiten ohne APs auszulesen
Checkaxe
Was ich benutze ist ganz normale Webrequests
Einfach 5.950x
Mindestens bei der Grafikkarte muss ich dann auch so machen
Dann muss ich dann gebe ich eh ein 9.903.090 RTX
Und dann muss ich alles ausgeben was der findet
Ja
Das ist aber nicht so einfach Generic zu machen
Weil in dem Fall ja
Aber das heißt ja nicht immer dass ich die Zahl im Suchtitel überprüfen muss
Ich muss glaube ich noch gucken ob die Produktkategorie stimmt
Ja muss ich mir überlegen
Kleines Neural Network trainieren easy, kein Problem
Weil man beschränkt das halt wirklich nur auf ein paar Sachen
Und ich mach die jeweiligen
Produktseiten da von Hand rein
Aber das ist halt auch kacke
Da drehst du ja ab bei
Da muss ich mir mal irgendwas überlegen
Aber will eben auch sein Leute ich hab Hunger
Ich geh jetzt was essen
Nach Herstellernummer
Oh das ist natürlich eine gute Idee
Stehen die denn da drinnen
Das muss ich jetzt mal kurz nachgucken
Also gucken wir mal bei alternate
Ne Gebrötchen
Nummer stimmt Herstellernummer
Ja guck mal hier
So und steht das bei und steht das bei alternate auch drinnen
Da muss ich aber auf jeden Fall auf die auf die Detailseiten gucken
Ach ja ja genau nach der nach der e an kann ich gucken
Ja das ist das ist wahrscheinlich echt das einfachste
Weil dann weiß ich auf jeden Fall ob das stimmt
Das habe ich allerdings auf der auf der Übersichtseite nicht
Gut ja dann dann muss ich eh auf die Detailseiten gucken
Dann muss ich auf die Detailseiten gucken
Und dann kann ich auch diese komischen Metatext verwenden
Ja
Dann gehe ich über die Suche
Und gucke ob ich was finde
Und dann gehe ich einfach sagen wir mal die ersten fünf
Also ich suche dann also dann muss man sich einfach darauf verlassen
Dass die Seite die die die Suche auf den Seiten halbwegs funktioniert
Ich suche dann einfach nach sagen wir hier
Doch das geht ich suche dann am die Reisen 95
So und dann nehme ich einfach die ersten fünf Ergebnisse von der Suche
Und gehe auf die Detailseite und guck ob dort die
Wichtigartikelnummer drin steht
Kannst du die e an in die Suche eingeben
Aber das wäre natürlich noch cooler wenn das funktioniert
Ja easy funktioniert
Ja das ist ja noch einfacher
Ja das ist ja noch besser
Dann muss ich mir einfach alles was ich supporten will
Die e an voraussuchen was ja kein großartiges Ding ist
Naja okay busy komplizierter wird es bei den ganzen
Grafikkarten weil die Grafikkarten gibt es ja von unterschiedlichen Herstellern
Das ist aber kein Ding
Da mache ich mir einfach mal eine lange Liste mit allen e ans drinnen
Bei minefactory ja das können wir mal ausprobieren was passiert
Aber minefactory sucht was nicht verfügbar ist
Ne aber das ist okay wenn er es nicht findet
Dann weiß ich es ist halt einfach nicht lieferbar nicht da
Genau du willst nicht irgendeine Sache aber du musst dafür erstmal weil
Das weiß ich ja gar nicht wer das alles hat
Ach echt?
Okay dann gucken wir mal
Weiß es gibt nur den tray
Den haben die hier gar nicht oder
Asus und MSI ja die haben alle unterschiedliche Sachen
Aber da muss ich mir halt einmal eine lange Liste generieren
Das wird auf jeden Fall das wird auf jeden Fall funktionieren
Und so genau liest du den Kram aus
Dass ich mich benachrichtigen lassen kann sobald Produkte verfügbar sind
Aktuell ist es ja so öfter und vor allem was die für einen Preis gerade haben
PogChomp ja aber sowas von PogChomp
Ich PogChompe mir jetzt was zu essen und danach spielen wir eine Runde Battlefield
Aber eh nicht im Stream
Bis dann machts gut, see you